hello.
Hello.
What's up, doggy?
I need help.
Okay.
Help is on the way.
I'm in the middle of a match.
I'll try to wrap this up.
And then I got you.
Okay.
Alright, no problem.
So what's been going on?
You've been playing a little bit?
I am...
Okay, I just got to Silver.
But I was like hard stuck Bronze 5 for like 5 hours.
Okay.
And so I'm like... I can't...
Clearly, I'm doing something wrong.
And I was stuck in Bronze 5 for 5 hours.
No, you're making progress.
There's nothing wrong.
That's good.
I don't know what I'm doing.
I'm just...
I'm not doing any combos.
I'm just abusing the same moves over and over again.
No, that's fine.
That's fine.
You don't need combos.
You're playing Geef.
Oh, God.
Oh, I hit Rematch.
My bad.
I was trying to...
Okay.
Just give me a few more minutes.
All right.
Sure.
Okay.
But you don't need combos as long as you have your strats.
Was there anything in particular?
I think I need better strats because I'm getting my ass beat.
Okay.
I definitely need better strats then.
Maybe this time I can watch you play some games and just see how it's going.
All right.
Because I kind of see it in the natural environment.
Meanwhile, I'm getting Geefed over here too.
We can watch my replays of my last couple of matches and just see what I'm...
Yeah, we can do that.
Yeah.
Give me some advice.
We can identify what we can patch up and exploit.
Is he dead?
No.
Okay.
I'm ready.
So...
Yay.
What's your CFN again?
Okay.
It is this.
It is...
Oh my God.
I posted it onto the screen.
Okay.
Let's see.
Not do Honda.
Honda.
So is there any particular replay that you think would be good to look at?
Like where you're super struggling or something?
I don't know.
Everything is now...
I did so many ranked matches.
Okay.
It's all a blur right now.
I don't even know.
Okay.
Let's look at a little...
Everything's a blur.
A loss and a win.
So I'm going to pull up one of your ranked matches right now.
Let's see.
I was stuck at 4,700 to 4,800 for like three of those hours.
I just kept going back and forth.
Okay.
I'm going to look at a Ryu match.
I don't know.
You won that one.
You kind of bodied them.
Good job.
Let's look at one where you lost.
You went back and forth with this person, actually.
Let's look at when they beat you and see what happened.
Add replay.
Let's add that.
Let's see how you beat them.
You're beating up on Kens, it looks like.
That's good.
A lot of these matches, you're going back and forth against these players.
I don't know.
They're not going to have as many players.
This is good.
You're adapting.
Okay.
Let's see.
I'm streaming on Twitch right now.
I don't know if you want me to screen share, or if you can watch it on Twitch.
I can watch it on...
I'll watch it on Twitch.
Yeah.
Okay.
Because I'm pulling up your, the first match here.
So this person, you ended up beating them in the first of two, which is good.
You know, one game is just one game.
But winning this set is what's important.
Did you mean to do that drive reversal?
That wake up move?
Is that a new thing you've been doing?
I didn't really talk to you about that.
I don't know.
I don't even know anymore.
That's not a bad idea.
Let me turn on...
Let's turn on your...
Oh, my inputs are mad.
We're going to show the inputs.
We're going to see the dark secrets behind what you're pressing.
I know for sure my inputs are fucking mad.
Okay, so...
Let's see.
It's okay.
Don't gotta be ashamed about mashing.
Okay, you're mashing.
See, you're mashing wake up DI there.
Hold on, I gotta get used to this control.
See how you mash wake up DI right here?
Yeah.
Maybe you're thinking like, oh, DI, like a panic move to like get them off you, like armor through.
But if you do this on wake up, just holding DI up, and forward, you do this move here, which pushes people off you.
And that's called the drive reversal.
And that's not a bad move, actually.
You can hold that.
Rather than mashing it, you just hold DI and forward on wake up.
Like, so you're on the ground, just hold those two buttons together.
And then when you wake up, you'll do this get off me move.
And it's a defensive option.
That's not a bad thing to do.
So if you want to do wake up DI, though, don't hold forward, just mash it without a direction.
If you want to do the wake up drive reversal, hold forward and mash it.
But that's a pretty good option.
To get them off you.
I didn't mention that before.
It's actually pretty good.
Okay, yeah, I was wondering why sometimes I do that and sometimes I'm not.
Yeah, if you want to just always get DI.
Gotcha.
Yeah, just do it without a direction if you want to get DI.
Okay, you're mashing... something.
What is...
Ah man, modern is so confusing.
Because I don't even know what you're mashing.
The game is just telling me...
Oh my god, hold on.
Stuff happens.
It's showing a fist icon.
I don't...
God, modern controls is so weird.
Sorry.
For 10 years we never had this and suddenly we have it.
I don't know what this... grab?
Is that what that is?
Okay, you're mashing grab.
Okay.
I didn't see a fucking fist icon.
Going crazy over there.
Yeah.
So that's not the move you want to mash.
So the one thing...
I can block.
Yeah, you can try block.
I know.
But the one thing I want you to mash is...
If we're going to mash, let's just try to make it square.
Crouching and then square.
That's the move you want to mash.
If you're going to mash.
It's going to happen.
You're going to panic and you're going to start mashing.
But let's try to make it square.
That's the one thing we can try in those situations.
Nice.
Yeah, I think you're getting knocked down and then he's just kind of smacking you around.
Yeah, when he...
When they smack me too much, I just...
I don't know what to do.
I'm just...
Blocking is good for that.
I just want them to get off of me.
Yeah, blocking is good for that.
It does...
It legitimately does work.
See how you block there and then you got to counterattack?
You block for a second and that let you do that DI.
Okay.
Nice jump.
That was godlike.
That was really good.
Oh, sorry.
Hold on.
Fucking controls.
I hate the replay controls.
Yeah, that jump in was really good.
And I like how you paused and then did the grab.
That's a perfect jump.
See, if you had done that again, so this time you did jump medium, which is jump X, right?
Yeah.
And that was a perfect jump.
And then you jumped again, which was a good jump also, but you didn't press anything there.
You didn't press the X.
If you did the exact same thing again, that would have beat him.
He wouldn't have been ready.
Oh.
Okay.
So, you have the idea of the jump.
Just always do that jump X at that range.
Okay.
And then, yeah, he just mashed.
Like, yeah.
I mean, he just committed.
Like, that's just a guess.
That's his big invincible super.
So, I mean, sometimes they guess with that.
If you try to do offense and you get hit by that, that's not a big deal.
The only thing I can say is, yeah, on wake up, just try to block a little bit more.
Or if mashing, we're mashing square.
And then those jumps, your jumps are actually really good.
Just press X.
Make sure to use it with jump X more often.
Okay.
You did it sometimes, but not other times.
And those times when you didn't do it, if you did press X, you would have bodied them for it.
Okay.
But is that the common theme?
Like, you feel like you're getting knocked down and then being mauled?
I just don't block.
I just...
Yeah.
Like, I would block at the next round when I realize, oh, they're fucking pummeling me.
Right.
Maybe I should start blocking.
But at that point, it's already too much.
It's too late.
Well, that wake up...
I just go, like, super aggressive first, and then...
Right.
And then...
But then there's some of them that are more used to, like, super aggressive plays, and then they aggro me back, and I was like, wait, you're not supposed to do that.
And then it takes my brain a bit to register, like, I should be blocking now.
Right.
Like...
Yeah.
Yeah, you're mashing every knockdown.
I like that run grab, though.
Okay.
That wake up DI, I think, would be good to use.
I didn't teach you about that, but yeah, let's try doing that.
So just hold forward and DI and wake up, and you'll push them off you.
If they're mauling too hard, that's a guaranteed get off me move.
And so you don't have to block.
You can just hold forward and DI.
It costs a bar, though, so you can't do it forever, but I think that'll help you in a lot of these situations.
Yeah, that's tricky.
When they're in the air, you can't do the grab.
Yeah.
You can do the lariat.
It's like, what happened?
Yeah.
It's hard to recognize in the heat of the moment.
But if you can, instead of pressing triangle, do Dauntless Triangle there.
Nice.
And I see you keep doing Crouch Fierce.
Oh, nice auto combo.
Okay.
Very nice.
Yeah.
When you're doing Crouch Fierce, are you trying to do one of the...
Oh, sorry.
By Crouch Fierce, I mean Crouch Circle.
Yeah.
Sorry.
I'm using...
That's not even Street Fighter terms.
That's like boomer Street Fighter terms.
Like the long kick?
Or the one where I spin?
There's one where he lunges with his arm upwards.
Oh, the forward down?
Oh, yeah.
The down circle is really bad.
The move you're not supposed to do.
I see you doing that a lot, actually.
I'm guessing you might be trying to do something else.
No.
Like the one where he does the little spinny kick when he lands on the floor.
That's for...
Okay.
Yeah.
So that's forward and circle.
There's that one.
Wait.
There's another?
There's like...
That circle has like five different moves based on every direction.
Okay.
So I think...
Because you keep doing the one with the punch where he like spins and punches up, and that move sucks.
Oh, that one.
Yeah.
So I'm trying to figure out what you're trying to do there.
But I'm guessing maybe you're trying to do like forward circle where he does the big cartwheel kick.
Yeah.
I'm trying to do that.
Okay.
Yeah.
I guess you just got to try to be a little bit more careful about your button presses there.
Like just hold forward when doing it.
Because the other one that you're not doing as much is just the circle without any direction.
And that one is really good.
We just like don't press any direction, then press circle or hold it.
And he does the big charge punch.
Like...
Okay.
That one I think you can do a little bit more.
Yeah.
That one I've been doing.
That one I've been doing after the cartwheel kick.
Okay.
Because then sometimes it hits.
That makes a lot of sense.
Yeah.
That's a really good move to do like after another attack.
Right?
Because then they're going to try to counter attack you and then you hold that.
That's a really smart idea.
So I would just say like all those times you're getting that down heavy punch, like sorry, down circle.
Just try to like be like, okay, let me like get my left hand out of the way here and just press circle.
And you'll get a much better move.
Yeah.
So that's a really good move.
I think you got fucking bodied on this one.
Akuma is tough.
Yeah.
Akuma is really hard.
Especially if they know how to actually throw fireballs.
Good start.
Nice.
Yeah.
Hell yeah.
Oh yeah.
He just starts grabbing me.
I'm like, what do I do?
I'm supposed to be the grabber.
Yeah.
He's grabbing you.
You got to grab him.
Grab back.
That's like the guess.
Yeah.
Like ideally on wake up.
Throw a loop.
Right.
So the idea should be like, is he going to hit me or throw me?
And that's why usually on wake up you block or tech throw.
And there's times where you definitely press buttons, like it gets more subtle.
But if you play someone who actually can hit you properly, you're going to be forced to block and wake up.
But the driver reversal, the forward and DI on wake up, that beats both hits and throws.
So that move, we should practice that because I think that'll help get all these players off you.
Like they're all kind of rushing you down.
Yeah.
That move will...
Nice.
Hell yeah.
I like that you recognize the level three and you start mashing it.
That's good.
Yeah.
It's my emergency.
No.
Perfect.
If I'm going to lose, I might as well use it.
Yeah.
If they're pressuring you, that's why that super is so valuable.
That never goes away, even at the highest level.
You're scared of that move.
So that's why people will back off.
These defense is kind of bad before that super.
So like getting mauled as Geif, it happens to all Geif players.
You did it again.
See, you just did wake up, driver reversal on accident, but it knocked him off you.
So if you can harness that...
Yeah.
Nice block.
Nice punish.
Oh, this guy's mashing.
Yeah.
Okay.
He got lucky.
Yeah.
I think the only thing I can say is if you're far away from them and you're mashing on wake up, like there's no reason to match there because you're not even going to reach them.
You do need to like just try to let yourself stand up and maybe walk back and like try to get back in the game.
Yeah.
It's just...
I know.
My biggest weakness is zero defense.
Right.
Yeah.
I mean, that just takes time, right?
When you're in the heat of the match, all this coaching shit goes out the window.
So that's very normal.
But that's the only thing.
It's like if you're...
Yeah.
Do some panic mashing up close, but if you're at a distance that should be your time.
Like, okay.
They're far from me, like try to take a breather there.
And that's a break in the action.
Cause a lot of these characters are going to have fireballs and things like that, where they can...
Oh, yeah.
They can throw that out to lock you down, to keep you from mashing at that moment.
Yeah.
And you don't even have a move that can hit them from that far, really.
So there's not even...
Even if you mash and the move comes out, like, you're just gonna miss.
Right?
So that's kind of what you should be thinking.
Like, if you're in range to hit them with a move, then sometimes mashing, like, your square is good.
But if you're too far away, like, just be like, okay...
It's like a cat and mouse game with Gief.
Your whole thing, you're trying to get back in.
So if they knock you away, just accept that.
And then just try to wake up and, like, not mash.
And then try to work your way back in.
That's kind of the main idea.
Yeah, like, Chun-Li also has, like, a really good keep out game.
So she can throw fireballs from far away.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, yeah, this one.
No, I definitely got fucked here.
Silver too?
Yeah.
Oh, they know.
They know.
What are you doing here?
You're literally so far above me.
And then I blocked you.
Wow.
We'll worry about that later.
I was like, I was not having a good time.
I was like, I don't want to fight her again.
Like...
Uh-oh.
Okay.
She clearly knows what she's doing.
Yeah, the Lariat, like, all those times you're pressing Lariat, I think just try to press Stand Fierce and...
Sorry, Circle.
Press Circle instead.
Instead of Triangle in those moments, Circle.
Like that, that spin move...
Yeah.
It's only good if they're already jumping or something, especially against opponents that start slowing down.
But you can just keep pressing Circle or, like, hold the Circle.
I was just like, oh, man, I think she's going to jump at me because she keeps jumping.
I don't know what to do when I get Perfect Parry.
Like, she just jumps behind me, like...
If you land a Perfect Parry and they're on the ground, just mash Triangle.
You get a free Command Grab.
So, yeah, if you are in a situation, you did it again.
See how good Wake Up Drive Reversal is?
You keep doing it on accident, that move is really good.
So, we'll go to Training Mode and practice that.
Yeah, this guy, they have combos.
They know what they're doing.
They have combos.
Yeah, they baited.
See, they knew about your Wake Up Level 3.
Yeah, they know what they're doing.
No!
Yeah.
That's understandable.
They were ready for the cheese.
They actually belong in that Elo.
But wait, you played them again.
So, you beat them?
Oh, it's a different one.
No, I played it different.
No, I blocked them and then I played it differently.
Frustration out on this Chun instead.
This person might be more your speed right now.
Yeah, they're not ready.
That's good to start with.
Yeah, I would start with that.
Because I'm like, if they don't block the first hit, most likely...
There's a chance they won't block the second one.
So then I was like, I'll just keep doing that until I realize that they know the matchup.
That's smart.
Yeah, if they don't jump it...
And the thing is, so in the tournament, they're gonna have coaches who will probably tell them, like, oh, jump that, and they might start adapting.
But it's definitely good to throw out in the beginning and just see what they know.
And, you know, just slow down if they start jumping it.
Nice DI.
Okay.
Not bad.
The only thing is, like, your jumps again is jump X.
You did a few jumps without the X.
Yeah.
Oh, that was sick, though.
That was sick.
Like, there you could have done jump X, right?
All the spaced out jump ins.
Just throw an X on your jump and it'll be even stronger.
Yeah, see that Lariat?
It's not doing anything for you.
All your other attack choices, I think, are really good.
I just feel like the down plus triangle, it's not really helping you out.
Yeah, it was just, like, bad prediction from my part.
Because I was like, maybe she'll jump.
Well, what you're supposed to do is you're supposed to, like, wait and react to the jump.
And it seems like you're getting kind of at that level you might be able to do that.
Nice punish.
You could have done level three there.
That's the only thing.
Oh, okay.
I spoke into existence.
Yeah, wait for you to get up.
Oh, and then I missed.
No, that was that was a smart DI from them.
You had no option there.
Okay.
Wicked medium.
Yeah.
The only thing I would say is if you want to try to, like, do it the proper way, you can theoretically wait on the ground, see them in the air, and then press a down plus triangle.
That's an anti-air, right?
The whole theory with the jump ins is that you can react to it if you're not already busy thinking about other things.
So you don't need to press the lariat preemptively ever.
Okay.
I would say it's not even worth it to press preemptively.
I'd almost rather you let them jump and just stop thinking about lariat because I just don't think the lariat is helping you.
I think it just makes you kind of spin and then they punish you.
Then you're done.
You're beating up on Kens.
That's a good sign.
Ken is like...
I wish there was a Ken player on the beginner's side position.
Oh yeah?
You're confident it's Ken?
I think it's because Ken carries them all to platinum.
That's the problem.
There's so many Kens.
Yeah.
Ken is like the new player god character.
See, you're doing lariat preemptively.
Yeah.
Ooh.
Wow.
Yeah.
And you did driver reversal again.
And you didn't mean to do it, but that was a good driver reversal.
So we'll practice that to harness that power.
Nice.
Okay.
He knows how to counter DI.
So it seems like on a wake up you like to do DI a lot.
Yeah.
Which is good sometimes.
We'll try to swap that out with driver reversal instead.
Nice.
This guy's a nut.
Ooh.
That was sick.
Yeah.
That's perfect.
If you're jumping and they jump at you, triangle, that's perfect.
Yeah.
I do that more as a reactionary.
That's called an air to air.
You have the air to airs down.
Nice.
When they're in burnout, that's when you can really go hard with the DI.
So he has no meter.
To counter DI, you have to use your own DI, right?
Yeah.
So when you're in burnout, you can't use your own DI.
You can't do that.
So you should be even more confident just pressing DI when they're... if they go into burnout.
Nice.
Level three.
Okay.
See, level three would have killed right there.
That would have been a really good time to mash your level three.
So if you don't have level three, doing what you do right there is the best thing you can do.
If it's like the last round and you have level three, you mash the... what is it?
Like down triangle circle.
Mhm.
Yeah.
That's like just a bit of optimization, right?
You would have already killed them, but that's... that's... you have the game plan.
Okay.
So I think we want to practice wake up drive reversal and there's one more thing on defense you can try.
I don't think you ever back roll on wake up.
There's a back roll?
Yeah.
If you mash kicks when you get knocked down, you'll roll backwards instead, which will make more space away from the opponent and it can help you wake up block a bit more.
I don't think it makes sense.
I've never seen a back roll.
Yeah.
It just started to click.
I was like, wait a minute.
She's never back rolling.
And that's also why they're getting such good pressure on you.
Yeah.
Okay.
What's a... you available to hop in a lobby and just try that out?
Yeah.
Let's do it.
How do I do it?
Let me send you an invite.
Okay.
I sent you an invite.
Oh.
Do you know how to accept it?
I assume it's...
You got to go to the...
CFN?
No.
It's a little weird.
You got to go in the fighting ground, go to the far right menu, which I think is like custom room.
Yeah.
And then there's like a custom room option.
Invitation.
And then view invitations.
Yeah.
Whoa.
Hey.
Okay.
You're in the training.
All right.
Join you there.
Nice.
Okay.
So, I think the first thing we should try...
Yeah.
...is just doing your wake up drive reversal.
So, I'm going to knock you down with this move here.
Oh.
And then...
You almost had it here.
Let me turn your inputs on so I can see what you're doing.
Okay.
So, when you wake up, after you get knocked down, just hold forward and your DI button.
You don't press it.
Just hold both buttons.
Yeah.
So, on wake up, you just hold it.
So, just hold forward.
Perfect.
So, you see how...
Yeah.
...it just sends it to you.
It just sends you...
Yeah.
So, that beats throws.
That beats strikes.
That beats whatever.
Right?
So, you can just hold that.
Yeah.
Now, the only thing is, technically, it's unsafe.
So, if they walk up and block, they can punish you.
But your opponents at this level are not doing that.
They're just like...
Okay.
...pressing random buttons.
Oh.
Yeah.
So, you got DI there, which does work sometimes.
If you want to do DI, just press it without the...
Just mash it with no pressure.
Yeah.
But I would say most of these times when you're waking up like that, you should be doing... just hold forward and DI.
It'll work more often.
Okay.
Yeah.
The other thing is the back roll.
So, some things you can't back roll.
So, Gief, like all his command grabs, you can't back roll.
That's kind of like what makes him... it makes him able to approach after.
Like, you kind of have to just get up again and hold the pressure.
Okay.
But other attacks...
What can you back roll?
Gief might be a bad example.
Lariat.
Lariat you can back roll.
So, if I knock you down with Lariat, just mash two kick buttons.
Mash two kick buttons?
Uh-oh.
Or...
What is it for...
Which one?
Actually, what is it for Modern?
God, Modern...
Here.
Do Lariat to me.
Okay.
Do it again.
Oh, that's the first time I've ever seen that.
Okay.
I think it's your circle.
No?
Okay.
Do it again.
I do X and circle.
Let me try...
Do it one more time.
Okay.
Square plus X or X plus circle.
It seems like just any combination of those two attack points with X, it'll...
There you go.
Oh, my God.
That's the first time.
Perfect.
And you see how much more space that builds?
Yeah.
So, most of the time, when you get knocked down, you're gonna be wanting to mash that.
All right.
And then, on top of that, you can combine both.
So, you can mash X plus circle and then start holding after you get the back roll, then start holding forward plus DI.
Okay.
And that way, you get the back roll plus wake up drive reversal, right?
Yeah.
There you go.
You're combining the defensive options.
That's, like, your ultimate way, like, build some space and then get them off you.
Mm-hmm.
And then look at that.
Oh, I see.
You can walk up and press heavy or walk up and press X or, you know, drive rush in.
Uh, chat's asking, when do we not back roll?
Yeah, sometimes, I think at your level, you should always back roll.
Sometimes, you don't want to back roll because it's better to quick rise to let them not push you to the corner as much.
But I think for you, I think back roll every time is a good standard for now.
Usually, it's, like, you back roll 90% of the time, then there's the exception when you don't back roll.
So, yeah, any knockdown, back roll, and then you can try, uh...
that.
Nice.
So, that knockdown, you can't back roll just fine.
Oh, yeah, I can.
Yeah.
The other thing, um, you don't use this move that much.
Down, forward, heavy.
This move is super good.
Yeah.
I usually, yeah, I default to this move instead.
Yeah, this move has more range, actually.
So, from further away, you can do that.
But if you're close to them, I mean, you can just...
do this.
Because if people are mashing, like, they're just gonna get knocked down over and over.
This is your, like, hey, please stop mashing and block move.
Okay.
See, I wasn't good enough, but...
I see.
Theoretically, you shouldn't be able to do that.
Okay.
Yeah.
So, until they show you something else, you can also just throw this out a bunch.
It's really good.
All right.
Yeah.
So, if you try it...
And if I try to, like...
Yeah.
And the other thing is, if they get hit by this, they can't back roll.
So, you can use that...
Oh, I see.
...to approach as well.
Like, it says hard knockdown there on the screen.
I have to get this one way, so you can gain ground.
So, you know, if you're confident, that's when your drive rush SPD comes in.
Okay.
Like, you can drive rush in, then SPD.
Yeah, you gotta learn the timing a little bit.
You have to delay it.
Yeah.
But that's the idea.
So, in the corner, you don't have to drive rush, but, like, mid-screen, that's what lets you...
Perfect, right?
So, if you land that mid-screen, because they're far away...
Yeah.
...and then you're, like, struggling to get in, you're in.
Perfect.
Okay.
So, that's why it's such a good move, because the reward is so good, right?
If you land that, suddenly you're in their grill and they're terrified.
Or, like, you know, the other moves.
Oh, no!
Nice.
There you go.
And then, you know...
Yay!
The other thing is, you didn't use any drive rush SPD after landing your command grab online.
Did you...
Are you dissuaded from doing that?
Because when you play the CPU...
Wait, drive rush SPD?
Like this?
Yeah.
And then...
And then drive rush again.
Oh, no.
I did it earlier in the other match... in pre... earlier matches.
And then I kept getting... they kept jumping, so then I just stopped doing it.
Okay.
Yeah.
I mean...
It's smart that they jumped it.
The idea there is that you're then supposed to mix up different options out of the drive rush.
So...
Yeah.
I don't want to overload you with options, but the basic thing that's super scary is your forward and medium out of drive rush.
So, this thing gets you in, and then they have to guess right away, even if they block it.
So, you can do that.
Okay.
Drive rush forward and then medium.
Or, sorry.
I keep saying the wrong buttons.
Forward X.
And then when I block that, or if I get hit, then you can do triangle right after.
Oh.
Well, no.
And then do triangle.
Yep.
Oh, okay.
This move is super good because it covers a lot of ground.
And then...
And then you can block it.
And then you can press right after.
And then if you don't want to do the triangle...
Yeah.
This is amazing.
So...
Okay.
So, like, try landing the triangle and then drive rush forward X and then triangle again.
And try looping that.
Okay.
Just to get a feel for it.
So, I see something wrong with the way you're inputting it.
What...
You need to...
You're not getting the drive rush version of the knee.
You're doing drive rush stop knee.
Oh, okay.
So, the thing about drive rush is you're supposed to let it rip without pressing any buttons.
So, even if you're holding forward, it cancels the drive rush.
So, I'm holding forward here and it canceled the drive rush early.
If I let it go without pressing any directions, then he goes for further.
So, you don't want to hold forward and then do knee.
You want to drive rush and then tap forward X.
When you're ready to do it.
That's the only thing.
Okay.
Ah, oops.
What the?
Why can't it...
You're pressing the X a little bit too early compared to your forward.
Oh.
So, you're getting, like, stand X.
Okay.
There you go.
You got it.
Oh, there you go.
All right.
Yeah.
You should be glowing green during the knee itself.
There you go.
Yeah.
So, now do it here.
All right.
Oh no!
Yeah, it takes a while to synchronize.
There you go.
And then try to do it again.
Okay.
Now try to immediately do it here.
Like after you land the command grab.
Okay.
Try to just immediately go in and do it.
No!
I pressed circle.
Okay.
You can do the knee a little earlier, so that's what we're trying to figure out, is like the timing of... the earliest time you can do the knee, because that'll stop me from pressing buttons on wake up.
So yeah, that knee was a little late.
Let's try to do a little sooner.
A little sooner.
No!
I can't do it anymore!
Yeah, you're doing it.
You're doing it.
Let's try to do it much sooner.
Oh my god, please.
Oh god.
Please, please.
There you go.
Okay.
Now try to do a really early knee on this one.
That was pretty good.
You can do it even earlier.
Like as soon as the dry brush comes out almost.
You can just hold the forward medium during the dry brush.
Well, if you do that, then the dry brush gets cancelled early, but maybe that'll be easier.
Here, let me try something.
I'm gonna try doing it to you, just to make sure we do the easiest version of this.
Let's see.
Oh, no.
Oh no.
Oh my god, I hope for.
Cause that'll cancel the dry brush early, but maybe you'll get enough time.
Okay.
I guess you can theoretically just hold forward for this one.
If that makes it easier.
Yeah, okay.
Let's just hold forward because it does cancel the dry brush early, but you should do the knee so early that it'll still come out enhanced.
Oh, fuck off.
Alright.
Okay, I'm out of my groove.
There you go.
Now do the knee even earlier.
Yeah, let's hold four the whole time and do the knee even earlier.
Oh, come on.
Just, just early, just early.
Even earlier.
As early as possible.
My fingers!
Okay, give me a sec.
All right.
There you go.
Pretty good.
But do the knee even earlier.
As soon as you start dashing.
There you go.
Okay, finally you did it slightly too early.
That's good.
You changed your timing.
Now we have to do it slightly later.
Perfect.
There it is.
You got it.
You're getting it.
There it is.
How did I not grab you?
You did it so good that you are too plus to grab me.
There you go.
Yes, this is it.
This is it.
I'm telling you, you could, you could spin to win like this.
Like this is...
Yeah, maybe just slightly delay the triangle after the knee, but you got it.
Yes.
Okay.
You're becoming too powerful now that you have to slow down your offense.
Yes.
All right.
Okay.
See, that can happen too.
That's the idea.
I'm going to try mashing on wake up a little bit now after this.
So the knee should beat my buttons.
Oh, whoops.
There you go.
Now the problem is... Not mash triangle.
If you hit me, you need to, you need to press a different attack.
This is where it starts to get complicated because, uh, you can't grab me if the knee actually hits.
Oh okay.
So if that happens, you could... I don't know how complex you want to make this.
You want to keep it simple.
Um, you can just press square.
Okay.
Like just mash square, like we talked about before.
But if I block it, you should command grab.
Okay.
So now you got to, this is called hit confirming.
You're kind of recognizing if it hit or not.
Maybe crouch square.
Oh my god.
I mean, that's honestly not a bad option.
Oh my god, I keep fucking grabbing.
It's out of instinct.
Yeah, the knee... I think you're doing the knee too late now.
Yeah, you're just doing the knee too late.
No!
It's always faster than you realize.
There you go.
Yeah, that was a good knee.
Oh, whoops.
Perfect.
God damn it, I keep doing that too early.
Yeah.
Yeah, if it hits, you really have to delay.
I mean, the idea being, if you could have gone for a combo, the game doesn't let you grab.
You have to wait for me to recover from the hit, and then grab me after.
So that's why, at higher levels, the geese will then see if the knee hits, and then they'll do a combo on hit.
And if they block it, then they can do either buttons to bait people from jumping away from the grab, or do the grab if they think they're gonna block.
Okay.
So basically, we just want to...
The goal is you don't want this to not connect, right?
That's all we're trying to avoid.
That's because that's the worst case scenario.
So if you do this, you can just do this.
The crouching square.
And then when that finishes, you're gonna be at the range to press circle.
Okay.
So we can try a little bit of this.
Just the dry brush knee, and then just mash crouch square.
Okay.
It's gonna be a basic...
And then here, you can start doing circle.
And then do it... you can even do it again after, right?
Circle, dry brush knee, and then, you know, mix it up from there.
Okay.
But let's try dry brush knee, and then mash crouch square.
Oh my god, wait.
I don't...
You're doing crouching square now.
Yeah.
Oh, you're blending them together, I see.
You're doing crouching axe instead of crouching square, yeah.
No, okay.
God damn it.
Yeah, you're crossing the wires right now.
I'm gonna use this now.
Yeah, my wires are crossed.
There you go.
Okay.
Nice.
See, I try to mash after, and you see how you're counter hitting me?
That's why this is so good.
Yeah.
Like, people can't mash here.
If you time it all correctly, it's really powerful because of that.
Yeah.
Oops.
Nice.
And then after three squares, the last one's gonna not connect.
So that's when you're...
Yeah, so now you're at that range.
Try like a circle or something.
Yeah, yeah.
Okay.
Nice.
That was a really clean sequence.
Really clean.
Yay.
Yeah.
That's a great sequence.
Oops.
So the idea being anytime you're kinda like out of range of people and things are going your way, and they're far away, you can just try that.
Just dry-rush knee into square or dry-rush knee into circle.
Okay.
That's something to do from far away because I think at those distances, I see you doing a lot of like just this.
Yeah.
Let's just remove this from the strategy.
Okay.
This move is just not good enough.
So if you're that close, it's gonna be circle, a lot of circle.
I think you can just do this way more than you realize.
It's really good.
And then if they're far away like that, like after this connects, dry rush knee.
Okay.
And then you can even try to, you know, do instead of square, do the triangle here and there.
Like this pins people down so hard.
Whoa.
Okay, I don't know.
I don't know how to use this character.
That's the idea.
Let's see.
So same idea if you land this move.
So if you land the, yeah, dry brush knee after that as well.
Nice.
Yep.
Very, very good.
Yay!
Very good.
Yeah.
And also instead of lariat, just any of your heavies besides the down heavy.
So instead of this out here, I'd rather you just mash this, the down forward heavy.
Okay.
Or sorry, circle.
Let me use circle.
Yay!
My boomer brain keeps taking over.
Down forward circle or stance circle.
Yeah.
All right.
Because this move is just, I don't think it's worth it.
And then if these ever land.
And then you just keep doing that.
That is a counter.
Yeah.
I guess you got to be always careful about that out of nowhere.
And then the other thing you can do is wake up drive reversal, right?
Like the hold forward and DI.
Yeah.
Cool.
I'm on this side now.
Do you remember the wake up drive reversal input?
Yeah.
No.
Not quite.
I mean, it worked there.
Not that.
There you go.
Yeah.
All right.
Nice.
Now we're playing back to neutral.
So we've got these ranges.
See.
It's just so good to get through.
Yeah.
I was trying to do that thing you taught me yesterday, like the... that.
Like it doesn't work in my elo.
I don't...
Did you ever get enraged to do it though?
Yeah.
It wasn't working?
It wasn't working.
I kept my shit beat up and then they put me in the corner.
It might be a little too hard to execute cleanly.
Yeah.
There might be... you kind of have to mix up the variables a little bit maybe.
And I think also you're just having trouble getting clean pressure from that range.
Like it's so... this range is so chaotic that it might not happen too often.
So if it's not working, let's abandon that.
Yeah.
You'd have to get into this range and control a little bit too much.
So then let's just focus on... you can definitely use that jump.
That close.
The down heavy.
But just make sure also at this distance, anytime you jump...
Yeah.
That's that.
And then when you land, you can either do crouching squares or triangle.
Okay.
And that's gonna be your idea basically.
Like just...
And you can even do it again.
Yeah.
Right?
Like...
Okay.
I understand.
And then you can do it again.
Oh.
Oh, please.
Yeah.
See how good this could be?
Is that Percy?
Yeah.
Is this how your matches go?
I'm getting PTSD.
Yeah.
But you see the vision, right?
Like I'm trying to...
Well, I want you to exploit this too.
Yeah.
Because you do the jabs, the crouching squares, and that pushes you out.
But that also pushes you to the perfect range to then hold up forward and press square.
Okay.
And then jump forward square.
Or...
Sorry.
Oh, sorry.
Match square and then jump forward X.
These controls are like hieroglyphics to me.
I'm sorry.
Okay.
Nice.
And then...
Yeah.
So you only get three of those crouching squares at max.
So you can always do one, two, three, jump forward X.
One, two, three, jump forward X.
Two, three, then jump forward X.
Or that.
You know, mix it up.
But that's...
Yeah.
Then jump forward X.
Oh.
Oh, no.
Oops.
Yeah, jump X, square, square, square, jump forward, X, jump... yeah, there you go.
Yep.
I mean, really, you can just spam this.
And then eventually, if they're blocking after a jump in, you can do that.
Okay.
Oh, crap, nice.
So, to stop what I'm doing, that's when you would do Lariat.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
After I leave the ground.
So theoretically, you could sit around doing nothing, and if they jump, you press down triangle.
But that's a little... it's not that hard, but then you're kind of waiting for them to jump.
Sometimes it's better to just let people jump at you over and over and do very little.
Yeah.
Because then you can just do this every time they jump.
So I don't know if that's... that might be too much for you to handle at the moment.
It might be better to just try to take the fight to them first.
But that's the idea, when you would use that move.
Like, if they're doing this on you over and over, you'd wait for the jump part, and then you do down triangle.
Perfect.
Yeah, and then after the Lariat, you can try to, like, walk up and do your own pressure, right?
Yeah, yeah.
So now you can try to... yep, yep, yep, exactly.
Get your own turn after.
Yep, now you can try to do something.
Nice.
Yeah, that's a problem.
You gotta do it early enough.
Oh.
Okay, you know.
Yay!
Oh, nice.
Nice.
Oh.
Nice Jabs.
Definitely try mixing in like your command grab, right?
Yeah.
Like I mean, doing the Jabs is gonna be really good for really mashy opponents, because it's easier to just kind of check them like with that.
So if they're like constantly being hit, keep doing that.
If they ever start to finally block or sit still for a little bit, then you can start mashing the triangle.
Okay.
I understand.
Okay, I think I got it.
What do you do on wake up here?
I knock you down and I try to do it.
There you go.
There we go.
I did it.
You can try to jump in or walk up and do this or drive rush knee, right?
You have options now.
You're learning multiple techniques.
But now I'm on top of you.
I'm pressuring you.
So how do you get out of it?
Oh god, please.
Nice.
Okay.
Oh, very nice.
That was actually really good.
Yeah.
Oh, you got me.
Yay.
Nice.
Whoa.
So how do you get me off you?
That works sometimes.
I mean, that works too.
But sometimes it won't work.
Yeah.
The only thing is, it's okay to do any move.
The goal is to just do the moves that you intended to do, right?
Yeah.
So if you want to do wake up DI, let's do wake up DI.
But if you intend to do wake up drive reversal, let's try to get wake up drive reversal.
That's all.
Okay.
And so, so the secret again is you don't have to press the button more than once on wake up drive reversal.
You just hold forward and DI the whole time.
So if I knock you down like that, you just hold the buttons together without mashing.
Okay.
Perfect.
There you go.
If you want to do this though, the random DI, then mash it.
Then just start mashing.
Yeah.
Perfect.
That's hella damage.
I'm jumping over and over.
There you go.
Whoa.
Then I'm rushing you down.
And what do you do?
Okay.
Sometimes do that.
I would say let's try to default to wake up drive reversal though.
Okay.
Yeah.
Perfect.
Nice.
Now you can get in.
Yep.
There you go.
Okay.
I'm blocking a bunch.
So you know what time that means?
Yep.
Exactly.
It's throw time.
Yes.
Now some opponents will never, ever, ever be conditioned.
So if something's working, keep doing it.
On the off chance they start blocking.
That's the idea.
That's me.
Yeah.
I think our tournament players, they'll be coached.
So they might actually block eventually.
Yeah.
Against you, I would never command grab because you're not blocking.
So if you're fighting yourself, you got to understand the mind game, right?
Like, oh, this dude's a mashing scrub.
I'm going to keep doing the buttons, right?
That's kind of the idea.
Oh, they're trying to play smart and block.
I got something for that too.
All right.
And that's Zangief.
That's it.
And then the one last other thing to refresh, back roll.
So if you get, Zangief doesn't have many moves, you can back roll, but that one.
Yep.
Every time you get put to the ground, just, um, just mash like, uh, whichever one you prefer.
I'm doing X in circle.
Okay.
So whichever two, or you can do a square and X.
So, so you didn't get it there, but if you mash.
Knock me down.
I'm trying.
There you go.
Okay.
Yay.
And then the last thing you do is combine that with wake up drive reversal.
So we'll back roll and then I'm going to drive rush at you.
And you want to, after you do the knockdown, the quick rise, sorry.
After you do the back roll, you want to hold forward and DI.
Yeah.
Oh.
You mashed it again.
You got to just hold it.
Okay.
Perfect.
All right.
That.
Yay!
Your defense is so much more leveled up if you combine those two.
Oops.
Yeah.
Just remember to try to not mash.
Mash the first part, then the second part just hold.
Okay.
There you go.
You're going to have so much better defense after that.
Oh, but it worked.
It will work sometimes.
Yeah.
If you're feeling a DI, I want you to DI.
For sure.
Yeah.
But I think you're still mashing the input from what I see on the input side.
When you're doing drive reversal, you literally don't have to, yeah, don't match it.
Oh.
You see on my input on the counter, the ticker on the right side that shows all your inputs, when I'm doing break of drive reversal, you see how the number's going up?
Yeah.
I'm literally just holding the two buttons together.
Oh, okay.
Don't lift your fingers at all.
Just hold the two buttons together when you wake up, and that's how you'll get that every single time.
Okay.
See?
So I still think you're tapping.
You're tapping forward.
Hold forward and DI.
Don't...
The number should be going up on your input.
You should just be holding it.
There you go.
Perfect.
Woah!
So just hold it.
There you go.
You'll get it every single time if you just hold it.
Oh my god, this is the first time I see it above 50.
Yeah.
Oh, sorry.
I did a wrong move.
That's the wake-up input.
Perfect.
Yeah, you both back-rolled and you held...
There you go.
That's how you'll never accidentally get DI.
Okay.
Perfect.
Now, if you want DI, that's when you start mashing.
If you don't want it and you want drive reversal, just hold it.
Okay.
There you go.
Very nice.
Yay!
Yeah, that'll slow down so much of the mauling you're going through.
Yeah.
Oh, thank god.
Okay.
Alright, my defense has finally leveled up.
Yes, yes.
And after that...
You have to figure out how to get back in with things like your jump.
You know, jump X, the jabs, some of these...
Yeah.
Yep, see?
And then...
If you land that and you can remember to drive rush in knee, like, that's godlike.
Okay.
Oh, shit.
I can't do it on this side.
Get on the other side.
You're not going to be able to control what side you're on in a mash.
So you prefer player one side?
Yeah.
Okay.
I would advise practicing player two side, but I can try to...
No!
We can try to jockey for player one side or something.
We'll see.
I'll rig the coin flip when we pick the sides or something.
I don't know.
Oh, thank god.
Okay.
Okay, cool.
Don't worry, I'll tell them I know both sides.
Right.
And I'll be like, guys, I want the player two side, guys, please.
Please, can I please have player two side, guys?
And they'll be like, alright, we'll put her on player one because clearly she's bad at player one side.
Exactly.
Sounds like a plan.
Okay, I kind of want to watch you play a few ranked games.
Is that possible?
Oh, yeah, yeah.
I can screen share.
But I've turned the quality down, so...
The frame rate last time was crazy.
That was...
Yeah.
That was nuts.
If you can do that, then I can coach you through a couple of ranked matches just to remind you of, like, the techniques.
And then that way you can do it in a real match.
Oh, yeah.
And I think it'll sink in that way.
All right.
I'm going to use the bathroom real quick then.
Sounds good.
Okay.
I'm muted on the call.
What's up, everybody?
Hey, thanks for everyone tuning in and watching.
222Ray with the tier 1.
Thank you so much.
SlainRains with the big 4 months.
Thank you.
HurricaneRoad with the gifted sub.
LeonHartgard with the fresh tier 1 also.
Thank you so much.
Phoenix234 with the tier 1.
KaiserDaGod with the fresh prime.
Thank you so much.
ShogunNunto with the fresh gifted sub.
AnonymousGifter with the fresh gifted sub.
AHSC with the tier 1.
BillyDiamondExists with the gifted sub.
Thank you so much.
Gons2 with the tier 1.
JasraRavin with the tier 1.
RoroArt with the gifted sub.
Shake64 with the 4 months.
BallsterBlade with the fresh prime.
StoneTooth with the prime.
ZixQD with the tier 1.
NoH2O with the tier 1.
DrDerp388 with the 2 months.
Thanks for doubling your lease on the dumpster.
NotGuyIncognito with the tier 1.
TheCityBeast with the gifted sub.
Thank you very much.
Dragonlord607 with the gifted sub.
AnonymousGifter, thank you.
XGamer101 with the gifted.
NewmanRise with the tier 1.
Did I catch up?
There's a lot of subs.
Holy shit, what is going on?
I think I just got 100 subs.
I don't know what's happening.
Thanks everybody for subbing to the channel.
Hope you guys are enjoying the coaching sessions.
I got a sandwich here.
Have you tried spamming DP?
She punishes DPs.
We can try that, but she does punish DPs.
Yeah, I noticed the new camicolor plus September.
I just think it's crazy that you guys care about the camicolor that much.
My guess is thank you Capcom.
What's the camicolor?
It's a camicolor.
I don't know.
I don't think it's that special.
Does she have a DI combo for wall splat?
I don't know.
I mean, it would normally be like Hellstab Lariat.
I think we'll just do Lariat.
I'm not sure if she knows that or not.
Shakarni, thanks for the five months.
I am back.
Not comfortable being a sub.
More into being the Dom.
Trick Troll.
Hey.
Okay.
All right.
I'm just putting it on ranked matches.
Sounds good.
Then I'll put it on 33 frames maybe?
1080 for 30?
Like, maybe that would be better?
Just not whatever you put it on last time.
Oh, yeah.
At 1440 last time.
That was absurd.
Yeah.
Is it better now?
No.
Oh, okay.
Then I don't know.
We got to lower the quality to like 480p or something.
Oh, God.
Yeah.
So after this game, maybe the frame rate is atrocious.
I'm distracted.
Okay.
Focus.
I'll just watch.
Oh, no.
Now I'm thinking about the frame rate.
Don't worry about it.
Okay.
Let's just play the game.
It's okay.
Okay.
I can't get lower than 5k.
Oh, bro.
What the fuck?
Okay.
Nice.
Wake up drive reversal.
Let's try that.
On the next time you get knocked down.
Bro, please stop.
Okay.
You missed it there, but it's okay.
I was off my groove.
Okay.
I'm not thinking about my disc rate.
We're going to have to...
Let me see.
I'll excuse you now, but when we run into these tough opponents, we're going to have to rematch.
Okay.
It's 720.
As low as you can go quality wise.
480.
Okay.
It already looks better.
Is that better?
Much better.
Okay.
So it has to be 480.
There we go.
I can see.
Okay.
I don't know.
What the fuck?
What the fuck is she doing?
Yeah.
If she does that, I just block it.
Oh god.
Okay but what if she doesn't jump?
Okay, she does.
That was good though, for a second.
You were walking her to the corner.
That moment of calm was very good.
Okay.
It's over.
I don't think I belong, it's over.
You just gotta... oh.
Wake up drive reversal?
Can we do it?
Not quite.
Okay.
So the problem right now is we're still mashing on wake up.
So we just gotta reign that part in.
So just play your normal game.
Yeah.
And just try to hold forward in DI when you get knocked down.
That's the only thing we want to try this...
this match that's new.
Okay.
Okay, hold forward in DI.
So don't mash it, just hold it.
Alright.
Anytime.
Okay, you got it.
That's still a win.
It didn't connect, that's still a win though.
Okay.
Nice.
You won't jump right?
No she... oh my god.
Yeah, at silver 2 they're gonna know to jump.
Okay, same idea.
If you get knocked down, hold forward in DI.
Okay, it didn't work because they jumped over it, but you got it on command.
That's still a big win.
Okay.
I think she knows how to jump.
See, that didn't hit.
That wasn't a combo.
You could have blocked that.
So whenever you see like a big super flash, like the screen freeze and they're doing a super, just hold down back.
Because if they mess up the combo, it's not gonna punish you.
You're gonna block it.
So that's one thing about blocking is like, the reason they do those big super screen freezes is so that you can think about defense.
So...
Yeah.
She messed up her combo, you could have blocked that and then you could have mashed triangle after the super finish to punish it.
So, those are like telegraph moments like, hey, block.
If you're already getting combo, there's nothing you can do about it.
There's no harm in holding down back, right?
You're already getting bodied.
But if they mess up, you will block it and then you'll get a chance to counter attack.
So, I think that's a big thing is you got to be a little bit more comfortable blocking because these players actually have like real offense.
And they're just gonna steal all of you if you don't block.
Yeah.
That's sweet.
Yeah, let's just try blocking on this next wave coming up.
Nice.
You can punish.
Exactly.
See, you were...
The first time you blocked, you were rewarded perfectly.
There you go.
We're in the game.
No.
That's fine.
You got mixed up.
You got mixed up a little but that's fine.
You got him?
Very good.
Oh.
I like the idea.
Nice.
Oh.
Okay.
Good control.
I like your pressure after the command grab.
Oh.
What?
You did it a little bit.
That was a little too early, but you had the right idea.
Okay, let's try Wake Up Drive Reversal.
Perfect!
There you go, you're back in the game.
Okay, good blocks.
Okay, just block a little.
Did you get it?
Yay!
I got it!
Okay, you need one more hit.
This is evening up the game.
Ahhh!
Nice!
One more!
Okay, okay!
I would say, like, when you're super low in health, that worked out.
You can also just try Square.
Remember, Square is your safe poke.
Like, if you just need to tap it in, get that last little touch, Square is really good in those moments.
Okay, that's fine.
That's totally fine.
That's a throw.
That's fine.
Good defense.
Wake Up Drive Reversal.
I need to be out of here.
Nice!
There you go.
Aww.
Nice.
Good block.
Nice punish.
Oh, I thought she was gonna jump.
Oh my god!
You're cooking!
Let's go!
I'm doing it!
Finally!
Let's go!
Okay.
I don't know what I'm doing, but I'm doing it!
Big things are happening.
Okay, let's block.
Let's block.
Or not.
Blocking?
Nice!
Nice auto-combo usage.
That was really good, actually.
You found, like, the opening in the neutral right there.
That was really good.
Oh.
No, no, no, no.
Please, I'm sorry.
You're good.
Play defense.
Play defense for a little.
Oh.
You're still fine.
Don't worry.
I don't feel fine.
I don't...
Okay, you're gonna be in burnout now.
So, you might be screwed.
I don't feel fine.
If they know what they're doing, you're actually screwed.
But you're just down back, maybe?
Yeah, yeah.
Okay.
Don't worry, don't worry, don't worry.
Just wake up drive reversal on this one.
Hold forward and V-I.
Forward and V-I.
It's okay, it's okay.
You're playing the defense better, though.
It's like...
It's still guessing.
You're gonna get beat up sometimes.
But you're making good bets.
What the fuck?
She's listening to music.
Yeah, her level 3 activates her music.
It's illegal.
Yeah, there you go.
I like that.
The jump square.
Or jump axe.
Oh no.
Get your music out of here.
Yeah, her music sucks.
Music allowed.
Nice.
We can try jump axe.
Don't worry.
This doesn't do much damage.
Okay.
Nice defense.
Punish!
Oh, too early.
No!
Deep jump!
You're so alive.
Keep it cool.
You're good.
Okay.
I don't feel good.
When you're ready...
I'm not ready.
You can do like a jump axe or something.
But...
Okay, it didn't work out, but you had the right idea there.
You blocked and they did something unsafe and you tried to punish.
You just did it a little too early.
But you have the right idea.
And you see why blocking is good.
People will just mess up and you can punish them.
Nice blocks.
Yep, see?
You're blocking and they don't know what to do.
Oh my god, I'm killing it.
They're killing themselves.
I'm doing it.
Nice.
Oh my god.
That was fucking sick.
That was amazing.
Hell yes.
Let's go.
Nice.
Good blocks.
Okay, let's try wake up drive reversal.
Yeah.
Oh, it's too late.
Okay, it's fine.
You survived.
Nice.
Oh, I couldn't get the grab.
Yeah, because it hit.
That's when square is handy, right?
We get close, we try mashing some crouching square.
Oh my god.
Leave me alone.
There you go.
You got it.
Oh, I'm fucking tired though.
Yeah, you're in a bad spot.
Goodbye.
You're gonna die.
Wait a minute.
Okay.
Don't worry.
You got full meter this round.
You got your level three in case she starts mauling.
You're in a good spot.
What the fuck?
Okay.
Wake up drive reversal.
Oh, punish.
Oh, no.
She's doing everything.
There you go.
You got the drive reversal.
So you're ready to play.
No.
Let's just press the move.
That was crazy.
I'm getting nauseous from the frame rate.
That was really good.
Okay.
Okay, block it out.
No.
Okay, just block it out.
Yeah, block it out.
Ah, they threw you.
That was smart.
She's grabbing me.
Yeah, I think you're getting closer.
There's still...
You're losing a lot of life from still mashing and missing drive reversal.
But the moments are there.
You see what I'm saying?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
They end up just doing something unsafe and then you get a free triangle grab and then they lose a huge chunk of life.
So if you just keep working on that, just keeping it cool on your defense, you're gonna get so many more opportunities to punish them.
Okay.
And yeah, I gotta fix something with this video.
This is getting nuts.
I don't know.
I put it on the lowest, too.
I have nitro, so...
Maybe it's me?
I don't know.
Do you have nitro?
No.
Okay, maybe?
I'm old.
Stream attenuation strength?
What the hell is this?
I'm checking mine.
Recent video...
Do I need to check something?
Should I have hardware acceleration on?
Tell Doki to check stream quality parameter when choosing resolution.
That's what they said.
What the fuck does that mean?
I don't know.
We can worry about it another time.
I can check that later.
Yeah, right now.
I don't think we can check it right now.
I'm fighting a buff lady.
Okay.
Wake up drive reversal.
Yes.
Hell yes.
There you go.
Come on.
Come on, lady.
Yep, nice.
Very good.
Come on.
Bye, lady.
See?
You got that one wake up drive reversal then you dominated the rest of the game.
Ties it together.
Lucky.
Leave me alone.
You got the health.
It don't matter.
Perfect.
She's on a 7 win streak?
What the fuck are you doing?
You're about to end that.
Don't worry.
I hope so.
Alright, let's be careful with the meter.
Let's just use heavies.
Stand heavy.
Get out.
Oh, shit.
Never mind.
I'll get out.
Alright, lady.
You can have this area.
Sorry, lady.
Nice.
Easy triangle.
Very good.
Yay!
Go win streak for you!
And I'm leaving.
No!
What?
Doki, no.
Doki, these are the demons we have to fight.
It's not the external demons of your opponents.
It's your internal demons we have to fight here.
We gotta run it back.
Listen, I don't know.
You're like a menace in these green streets.
Send a message.
They'll remember that.
Don't worry.
They'll remember.
Good.
I want one person to remember.
Okay.
That's the same thing we want to send.
Oh my god, please.
Stop doing your leg stuff.
Yeah, that heavy is gonna be good.
I keep saying heavy.
Sorry.
Stand circle.
The big punch.
Yeah.
Perfect.
See?
Yeah, she's doing that at those ranges where that move is really good.
I guide her range.
Nice.
Get out.
Get outta here.
Very good, very good.
That's right.
Oh, shit.
She's gonna do a lot of DI's.
I'll do that again.
Come closer.
I'm sorry.
There you go.
She has no meter.
You can do DI.
You can do whatever you want.
No, she jumped!
You're alive?
Nice drive reversal.
No.
Oh.
Yeah, that was unlucky.
Nice.
Oh.
Yeah, against this kind of player, you're gonna have to wait for them to DI.
They're doing a lot of random DI's.
So, if they're on the ground, I would just wait for them to do the DI.
And then do yours in response.
Okay.
Oh, no.
Don't touch me.
Yeah.
Let them kill themselves, this kind of player.
They're gonna do something random.
They're gonna go into the air with that DB, the pinwheel, and grab them when they land.
And if they do random DI, just do your DI back.
This kind of player doing less is better, because they just do unsafe stuff all the time.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
Yeah.
See what I'm saying?
They're just kind of mashing them.
So, when you approach, it's kind of let them wake up.
So, you could have DI'd that in return.
There you go.
That's a punish.
Did she go first?
No!
Yeah!
I was first!
Or second!
So, you can just walk her down, and wait for something unsafe.
That's good.
So, just wait here.
Yep.
There you go.
Just wait.
Oh, I thought her thing was gone.
Okay.
Now I know.
Level 3?
That's right.
Get over here!
Yee-haw!
Yeah.
These kind of players, you don't even need to do any offense when they're knocked down.
Just kind of let them stand up, and be at a threatening range, and then wait for them to do something.
Oh, they ran this time.
See?
Oh, nice.
Okay.
I didn't want to fight them anyway.
Oh, they're scared.
Wait.
Oh, my gosh.
Why can't I?
Please.
You can change this to...
Change this to confirm, opponent.
That setting.
It doesn't have to auto-accept.
You can change it to confirm.
Yeah, I had that on because, like, I was just... no life grinding.
Okay.
What did your chat say to fix the video?
What did they say?
Chat, how do we fix video?
There might be someone who knows what's going on here.
Hardware acceleration?
Okay, I put hardware acceleration on.
Is it better?
Oh, wait.
We can't tell until...
The frame rate only drops when you're in the game, really.
Yeah, when I'm in the game.
But the resolution already looks better.
Well, I changed the resolution just now.
Okay.
Yeah.
I don't know.
I think it's better.
We'll see.
Oh, God.
See?
That's why we turn it on.
That orange bar?
Don't accept that.
Oh.
I've been accepting that all night.
Yeah.
So, let's see what they give you here.
See?
Yeah.
Okay, but it could be funny.
I mean...
You're not wrong about that part, but...
It could be fun.
It depends on what kind of fun you're trying to have.
I've played against so many people in Asia.
You've been having a really interesting...
Yeah, I saw your matchmaking.
I was like, why is this match...
It's a Chinese player.
Normally, you gotta reign in the connections.
Ooh, Wi-Fi.
But I do it.
Oh, why did I do it?
I'd rather you have taken the wired red than the Wi-Fi orange.
Why did I do it?
This is gonna be ugly.
I don't like playing against this character.
Just do your circle.
I thought it'd be funny.
Do your circle.
It charges and it'll...
Yeah, do that.
That'll beat his fireballs.
Okay.
I originally thought it'd be funny.
Aww.
What the fuck?
Oh my god, I can't.
You got it.
You got the idea.
There you go.
You're in.
Fuck you.
Fuck you, bro.
Nobody loves you.
You just gotta walk him down.
There you go.
Okay.
Time to walk him down.
Patience.
You can jump.
Oh.
Okay.
One more.
Nice.
Exactly.
See?
Your mom doesn't love you.
Wow.
Man.
We're just trying to have fun too, you know?
Wow.
Oh no.
He doesn't know what he's doing.
Don't worry.
Oh my god.
Please.
Leave me alone.
You're winning.
Yeah, I'm gonna stress it.
Yeah.
See?
Okay.
I swear to god, if you fucking do your perfect shit, I swear to fucking god.
So, when he's walking backwards, he doesn't have the big kick.
He can't kick you.
So when he's walking backwards like that, you can jump at him.
Yeah.
Oh.
If I had a little bit more HP.
No, that loses after three hits.
Really?
Yeah.
That's why it's not good to DI too often.
Because people can just hit you out of it if they're ready.
Okay.
Bye.
Don't worry.
He's gonna throw more fireballs.
So just wait for a little bit.
Nice parries.
Come on, bro.
You can walk at him and then jump X.
Okay.
Now don't jump.
Don't jump.
See how he's crouching?
There you go.
Now you could have grabbed that.
When he's crouching, he's gonna do the big kick.
Okay.
But if he's not crouching, you can jump.
Oh, please.
You're good.
Fuck this.
Nice.
Perfect.
It's not so bad.
You need some patience a little bit.
But it's not so bad.
You hit harder than he does.
Nice.
So you're gonna run it back, right?
No.
Wow.
Nobody's playing that in my division.
I don't have to worry.
Okay, I'll do 3 to 5.
Yeah, 3 to 5 is good.
And you don't have to do worldwide.
I mean, I guess if you do 3 to 5, it's better.
What if this person has really good internet?
From across the ocean.
I think the laws of physics kinda make that not relevant.
Done.
Okay, but what if he doesn't jump?
Okay, he does.
So he knows.
This guy's jumping at you.
So you gotta look to anti-air him.
Okay.
Or just down triangle if he jumps.
Oh shit.
Oh no.
Oh no!
Nice.
Oh sick!
Get out!
Get out of here!
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa!
Okay, maybe I'll get out.
It's fine.
I'm fine with that.
Oh no.
That was a bad reaction.
Yeah.
Nice.
Really good down-forth circle.
That was really good.
Nice.
Okay.
Good pressure.
That was fucking brilliant.
Yay!
Like, that was legit a high-level technique.
Like, that was amazing.
The mediums, or the X, and then stop and command grab?
Really good.
Stop.
Oh my god!
Can you stop doing that?
Please, sir.
This is a no-fly zone.
You can do more of the circle when you're standing around there.
Yeah.
There you go.
Oh no!
It's okay.
Wake-up drive reversal.
Okay.
You're gonna live, I think.
I live?
I think you... You have a lot of health.
You're evil.
I don't think so!
I...
You live.
Wake-up drive reversal.
Oh, shit!
Okay.
Nevermind.
It's too late.
Oh!
You got him!
Goodbye.
I don't think he dies, though.
I think he's dead.
That's CA.
Oh, shit!
Yeah, he's dead.
I broke his sixth win streak!
You cooked him.
Nice.
Okay.
Run back.
That's a good match.
Yeah.
Run back.
I wanna give a statement.
No, but he's... He's...
You're learning.
You're doing good.
But... I like giving a statement.
The statement will be when we win the tournament.
That's... That's the time to make the statement.
He doesn't know that!
Listen.
It's not about... He doesn't know!
This guy is just part of the training montage.
He's just a... He's a supporting character for, like, 12 seconds.
Don't worry about it.
Yeah, but I want him to, like... I want him to live rent-free in his head.
Listen.
I respect it, but at the same time...
We gotta do it when it counts.
Tournament, you can't run away after one.
Oh, shit.
That was the... That's not what I wanted to do.
Yeah, the heavies at that range are pretty good.
No!
Ah, yeah.
Super middle there.
Nice.
That was a good idea.
He just happened to jump.
Oh, no.
Oh, no!
He did that!
Okay, let's wait, and then when he jumps, down plus triangle.
Because he keeps just jumping at you.
Oh, my God!
He figured me out!
That was a good idea.
But this is when you counter-adapt.
This is what really tests you.
So now you're playing a real set, so...
Yep!
Jump X is gonna be really good against him.
Oh, fuck.
Okay, let's block.
Yeah, just block a little.
Nice.
Okay.
Jump X?
Perfect.
Square?
Yep!
Jump X and square.
Okay, but what if he doesn't jump?
He jumps every time.
Sometimes he doesn't!
He's jumping way too much, actually.
That's his problem.
Okay.
He's gonna jump every time.
That was an accident.
Okay.
Misinput.
Oh, God.
Just block, block.
Yeah.
Okay.
He can move first after that.
If he does that full charge punch, you just gotta block after.
Just block.
Block.
Yeah, there you go.
Now you can play.
Nice.
Don't... Okay.
Don't mash that one too much.
That's the only thing.
Okay.
Nice.
That was a really good time to use that.
Okay.
Just need one more good sequence.
Nice defense.
No, he countered it.
Don't worry.
Oh, goodbye.
No, no, no.
You have plenty of health.
Okay.
Oh, wait.
I'm on the right side.
Oh, what do I do here?
Just block, block, block.
No, no, like try like a jump X or something when you get closer.
There you go.
Oh, fuck it!
You had the right idea.
You just missed timed it.
That was smart though.
Yeah.
Okay, that was a good set though.
That was good.
The only thing I would say is that was a very jumpy player.
Yeah.
If we can get better at the anti-airs, like just keeping it cool.
And then seeing him jump and then doing the lariat, you could have controlled a little bit more.
But you started doing better when you were blocking on wake up a bit more too, right?
Uh-huh.
Because especially Ed, like a lot of characters, like I said, they'll try to hit you from a distance when you wake up.
And every time you mash into that, you're just giving them free damage.
So if they're not even close to you, they can't throw you at all.
There's no reason to not block.
What the fuck?
I parried that.
Is it because of your Wi-Fi?
Is this it?
You might feel it.
Yeah, maybe.
I paid.
Oh, God.
Okay, we got to block it out.
We got to block it out.
Okay.
Okay, that was a bit too much blocking.
He whiffed.
He did whiff like five throws.
Maybe at that point, we mashed some squares.
Nice.
My turn.
Good walk under.
Oh, whoa.
Yeah, that's not going to work against him.
Let's abandon that.
Let's try to do some crouching squares.
So let's block.
Nice.
Now, crouch square.
Perfect.
Oh, my God.
Please get me out of this corner.
Thank you.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
Jump X would have worked there.
Okay.
Let's run it back.
Hopefully, it doesn't run.
So...
When you're jumping over the fireballs, that jump X is really good.
And then if you also focus on wake up drive reversal, this guy is pressuring you super hard.
Hold forward in DI and wake up if you get knocked down.
And you'll get it.
Yeah, you did the jump X a little too early, but that's the right idea.
Okay.
Perfect.
And then you can just walk away.
He's going to do a random uppercut after.
So after you land a jump in, just block because he's going to whip a giant uppercut.
And then when he lands, you press triangle.
See?
He did it again.
If you would just block there, he would have landed.
You press triangle.
Now you can do DI.
I tried.
That's okay.
He jumps.
Yeah.
He's aware of that.
We had a block there.
See?
You got to block.
Every time you get in, he's just going to do that uppercut.
Just block.
Yeah.
Now when he lands, triangle.
No.
Just wait for him to land.
Oh, okay.
Yeah.
Oh.
Oh my god.
Get out.
Okay.
Just block.
Block.
Oh.
Don't try to do...
Against this kind of player, don't do anything.
Just do one move and then block.
Okay.
They are going to do something unsafe.
Oh.
Nice.
Good awareness.
Okay.
He's going to do it again.
So get one jump in and then we're going to block.
Oh no.
Block.
He tried.
He messed it up.
He's going to do it again though.
So just get one...
Block.
Do it.
Yes.
Exactly.
I can learn.
This kind of player, you let them kill themselves.
They are just going to do something unsafe every time.
Yeah.
Nice.
Don't do that.
Don't do that again, bro.
Okay.
Block.
Yep.
Now when he lands...
Oh no.
Too early.
Yeah.
It takes a while for him to land from that one.
That was just crazy.
Stop.
Okay.
Wake up drive reversal.
Hold forward and DI.
Oh.
He jumped.
Damn.
He read you.
Oh my gosh.
He hazard like a little bit.
Yeah.
You're just not feeling it.
He ain't familiar with the timing of his DP.
He does two hits like the one, two, and then he slowly floats down.
You just got to wait for him to hit the ground.
Okay.
So you got the strategy.
You just got to work on the execution.
That was good.
You're adapting.
Oh man, Rasheed.
Rasheed can be tough.
All right.
Let's go.
Okay.
But what if he doesn't jump?
We're not in bronze anymore, I'm sorry.
But what if...
It'll work on one silver player.
I believe.
I think so too, but if it doesn't work one time, it's probably not going to work the second time.
That's all we got to remember.
Okay, we got to block.
It's time to block.
Or that.
We can do that too.
Yeah, your low end drive meter is the only thing.
Okay, don't worry, you're not going to die.
You can do drive reversal again after this is done.
Don't worry, now you're out.
You knew.
Nice, just need one more.
Oh no!
Nice drive reversal.
No!
So close, so close.
Oh my god, he's already won!
Very good.
Perfect jump in to command grab.
Oh.
Oh my god.
Nice.
Perfect.
Woah.
Good defense.
Yeah, that was good defense.
Blocking it out, now you're back to playing the game.
Okay.
Oh no.
Bro, stop.
You're not cool.
You don't look cool.
Oh, I thought she was going to jump.
That was a misread.
Get out.
This person is also kind of like the Ken player.
Not as often, but they like to do the uppercut, the invincible uppercut.
Yeah.
So, it's also good to just get near them and let them wake up.
And they'll do the spinning move into the air.
And when they land, you can command grab.
Yeah, see if you were blocking there, you could have command grabbed that.
So...
Yeah.
Yeah, perfect.
They don't know what they're doing.
They're just going into unsafe stuff.
So, if you block out, they'll give you opportunities to punish.
Good defense.
Oh no, he knows.
Perfect.
You can level three or... yeah.
Okay.
Next time you can level three.
Don't worry, I'll base them.
Oh.
Okay, don't worry.
Just block.
Now you have to block.
So, you're in a bad spot.
I'm not going to lie.
Yeah.
Um...
Oh, that was good.
You lost a bit of meter.
Perfect.
Now you got to get out of the corner.
Oh my god.
I baited them.
That was amazing.
Your reactions are godlike.
Is he alive?
No.
Let's go.
Yeah.
If you see DI and you have level three, you can do that like every time.
If you're...
Oh yeah.
Maybe I'm doubting you too much.
That's...
That's like legit.
Yeah.
Because, you know, everyone at this level wants to do DI all the time.
You have like a fucking bomb that you can just throw at them every time they do that.
Good defense.
Yes.
They'll give you opportunities to punish when you block it.
I know.
Oh.
Nice.
That was really good.
Good usage of the down forward circle.
That's fucking right.
Yes.
Yeah.
Oh shit.
Sorry.
I mean, you're partying.
I'll shoot you.
I'm just feeling it.
I felt it.
Now you just play a little defense.
Play a little defense and you're good.
Okay.
Nice block.
Now you're back in it.
You're back in it.
Oh god.
Keeps doing that thing.
Drive reversal.
Very good.
Nice.
One more.
Oh.
Oh no.
Don't worry.
Just chill.
And you're good.
Yeah.
Just work your way in.
Nice.
Yay.
Yeah.
He does that.
Your pacing is so much better now.
Just because you're willing to block every once in a while.
And then you work your way in and then they just die.
I can't believe it.
I learned how to block.
Oh.
Not now though.
Not.
There you go.
Defense.
Perfect.
That's fucking right.
Oh shit.
Yeah.
Who says that?
Shit.
He'll do that every once in a while.
So annoying.
Well.
Empty.
That's fucking right.
You know what that means.
Oh.
Yeah.
He's asking for it.
There you go.
That's fucking right.
Oh.
Now I don't have it.
That was my bad.
Yeah.
Maybe regular triangle would have been better there.
But you have your level three.
So.
Yeah.
When it's time you can bust that out.
Oh.
Okay.
Block.
Just block.
Okay.
Now you can level three.
Yes.
Yay.
But he's alive.
Was that CA or...
I always forget his animation.
He might be dead.
Oh.
Okay.
No.
I knew he was not dead.
Okay.
Do you think he'll...
Yes.
Okay.
Nice.
Hell yeah.
Yay.
Yeah.
When you got level three, blocking a move and then mashing level three is too good.
Like you just need a tiny hint of blocking and then mash.
Right?
Yeah.
Are you on a win streak right now?
You're kind of cooking.
No.
If I won and done maybe.
You got to get the win streak the legit way.
I thought you got to get it done.
Okay.
This guy, he's in bronze.
He's playing Akuma.
He might be a nut.
So when...
Okay.
They're very aggressive.
So this is going to work.
Oh shit.
Nevermind.
That might actually...
Okay.
It didn't work.
You get one.
You get one at the start of the game.
Punish when he lands.
Yeah.
I get one.
This is going to work.
This guy, block and punish is going to be really good.
You can mix...
Yeah.
Okay.
Oh, sure.
Very good.
Picking your spots.
Maybe like a stand heavy.
Yeah.
I think stand heavy against this guy will work good too.
Okay.
Sorry.
Stand circle.
Oh God.
What's blocked.
That's fine.
Okay.
Now you're just going to work your way in.
And then maybe like a jump X.
There you go.
Now block.
Block.
No.
I pressed the wrong button.
Yeah.
It's hard to know to go for command grab after you hit them out of the air like that because it varies.
Sometimes they get juggled in the air.
Sometimes they fall down right away.
Yeah.
You got to kind of wait and see what's happening.
Nice.
No.
Okay.
This guy knows how to do...
I'm going to drive rush throw.
So he's smurfing.
Oh shit.
Okay.
Oh, I didn't realize my thing was gone.
Oh no.
He knows now.
Nice.
Okay.
Goodbye.
Level three.
No.
Block.
Oh, you're dead.
Yeah.
Oh, I quit.
That's kind of what he's doing.
Let's run it back though.
Let's see.
He might run.
I feel like.
No.
Okay.
Oh no.
No.
He wants to fire me.
Just pick your spots with the jump X.
And then we got to square him.
We got to square him.
Yeah.
The jump X.
Oh.
That's a good idea though.
The circle is good.
Nice tag.
Down triangle.
Oh no.
I thought he was going to...
Nice.
And then squares.
Oh no.
I'm sorry.
I'm so sorry.
Okay.
You got a chance though.
Oh.
He gave you a big chance.
Snap.
Nice.
Okay.
There you go.
Very good.
Snap.
Oh shit.
No more snap.
Snap.
Okay.
Let's block it out.
What if I do this?
Oh.
I almost got the grab.
You got to block.
There you go.
Very good.
Oh.
Nice.
That was so good.
Whoa.
No.
Oh.
I had...
Block.
Just block.
Yes.
Now punish him with a lance.
No.
You're alive.
Oh no.
You're dead.
Okay.
But you had the right idea.
That was good.
But you see what happened, right?
He was going for the combo and he should have killed you.
But people fuck up all the time.
So if you're blocking and they fuck up, you can then kill them.
So if you got the triangle there, he would have been dead.
So when people start hitting you, don't like give up.
Don't give up hope.
Yeah.
Everyone's fucking up all the time.
So just hold down back and then they might just give you a chance to kill them and you can win.
When you should have lost all the time.
It happens at every level, all the time.
I'm learning.
Yeah.
Like you almost won that game.
That was actually really close.
That guy was good though.
I think he's better than bronze.
Get out of this elo.
Smurfing in a video game?
That's illegal.
It exists.
We'll report them.
That's against TOS.
Yeah.
It might actually be.
I'm pretty sure.
It's like technically against TOS for every game.
No one's brave enough to report them, but I will.
I mean, the problem is you might just be getting your ass beat.
They're like, wow, this player's a scrub.
They get all your reports.
Every time I lose, it's a smurf.
I'm like, damn.
This person is salty.
What the hell?
I don't know.
Oh, they rejected me?
How dare they?
I reject you.
I'd be like that.
Yeah.
The only thing I think you're not doing as much that you could is just using the crouching square.
That's the only thing I think you can mix in at the closer ranges.
Cause, uh, like that's going to be your better.
And when you're doing it, try holding down and back when you do it.
So down back should be like your home position.
If you're not doing it, you're not going to be able to do it.
If you're not doing anything else, down back is the best way to block.
So you can be holding down back without mashing square, just to block.
And then when they, when they try to walk up to you while holding down back the whole time, then just tap square.
So like you should get used to that then it's like, just tap it to poke them as they approach you.
And so that's a really good defensive option.
And even offense, if you're unsure, like what to pressure them with up close, just do some crouching squares.
Like just tap, tap.
You don't have to mash it the whole time.
You can also just tap.
You can just kind of stagger it.
It's a good way to more safely poke them.
And then when you're further away, then go back to your other game plan of the X, the circles.
Yes!
My one worked!
Okay.
I told you!
You can do it until it doesn't work.
As soon as one, see two works.
Do it until it doesn't work.
If it stops working.
Okay.
All right.
It's gone.
It's over.
Yeehaw.
Well actually, maybe do one more.
Really?
Yeah.
Okay.
Against this player.
Yeah.
You got it.
Go ahead.
Have fun.
I knew it.
I knew I could do one.
And then good squares.
Those squares were really good.
Knowledge check!
Oh, okay.
No more.
She got...
Her knowledge was better now.
I actually don't believe it.
I think you might...
I could do another one?
I think it might still work.
I'm not convinced actually.
Oh my God.
Okay.
Now I'm convinced.
No.
They got it.
We got to play the game.
Yeah.
I'm lucky.
Sad.
I'm sad.
Oh, what the fuck?
Oh no.
Yeah.
You were kind of using your meter.
Okay.
We're going to block it out.
Some squares when they get closer.
Do you know you want to get closer?
That's where I get baited.
I don't think I'm going to win this match.
I think I might have wasted it.
No, no, no.
No.
I mean, I understand the hesitation to use the meter, but I think you can win this.
Yeah.
It's jump X, then squares.
Oh no.
Hold on.
Block it out.
Block.
Nice.
No.
My meter.
After you block big moves also, square is the best button to press.
Right?
Like to take your turn back.
Yeah.
So she did like a big bicycle kick thing.
You could have pressed square to take your turn back.
Holy shit.
She's so slow.
You're the slowest Cammy I've ever fought.
She's kind of...
I don't know.
She's kind of beating around the corner.
She might not need speed.
Okay.
Nice.
Square.
Yeah.
Square there.
Get out of here.
That was actually a good time to use it because you distracted her so much.
Oh my God.
Perfect.
Leave.
Oh.
Fuck.
I guess I'll leave.
Kind of cooked right there.
But you're good.
You got the health.
Square.
Yeah.
Okay.
Oh wait.
Drive reversal.
Okay.
Oh.
Get out.
Somehow that worked.
That was a good match though.
Please leave.
No.
You're going to have to learn to beat them all.
Consistently.
She's such a slow cammy.
Nice.
There you go.
Okay.
But what if like...
It would be funny if she still didn't learn.
Yeah.
Nice.
Oh my God.
Your circle's at that range.
Nice.
Okay.
Yeah.
But your stand circle will armor through all that.
Okay.
Block.
No.
Triangle.
Yes.
Perfect.
See those random supers like that where the screen freezes?
Just block it.
Yeah.
And land triangle.
Oh my gosh.
You finally did the fucking cannon shit.
Nice defense.
Nice.
Cool.
Oh no.
Okay.
There you go.
And then now stand heavy.
Yes.
Nice.
Level three?
Or that?
Yeah.
Yeehaw.
One thing to keep in mind, like if you think it's going to kill and you have level three, just spend it.
Like that way you can close out more games, especially on the final round like that.
Just being a little bit aware of that when you get the DI like that can really help you close out rounds easy.
So, anytime it's going to kill, just do level three like that.
Okay.
Oh, whoa.
Yeah.
That was good.
They are all running from you now.
Why are you all rejecting me?
They are running from you now.
Please.
I have fiber into me.
It's not that bad.
They know a modern gief waits on the other side.
They're scared.
Oh no, not another Akuma.
Damn, he's about to be silver three.
Alright, time to...
time to prevent the promotion.
Okay, let's see.
No way.
Yeah, yeah.
They're gonna throw fireballs.
Oh my god, you almost got him.
There is a way.
You know what, you deserve silver three.
Nice.
I knew you were gonna grab.
Triangle when he lands.
Okay, that's good enough.
Oh, okay.
That's good, that's good.
Oh, stop.
Nice.
Let's get some squares in there.
Oh god.
Oh, that was nuts.
Square, square, square.
Okay, your turn.
You're good now.
Just play the game.
Oh, no.
Don't worry.
You're alive.
He doesn't have these.
See?
Good defense.
Triangle or...
Oh, yeah.
Oh, no.
Okay.
Don't worry, don't worry.
This guy, he's scared.
Nice.
Stop!
Okay, you need to use a down forward circle on him.
The sweep.
Yeah.
That one.
Yeah, he's walking too much.
If they're walking around too much, just kick their feet.
Oh, come on.
I knew it.
I knew you were gonna fucking grab me.
Stop!
Okay.
He's waiting for you to jump now.
Oh, my god.
Okay.
We just gotta sweep him.
Yeah, yeah.
That's still the right idea.
Oh, god.
Oh, my god.
Oh, he knows.
How dare you adapt?
Yes!
How dare you adapt to me?
That was an amazing time to mash.
All
right.
You live.
No.
Yeah, you...
Oh, my god.
You're just throwing a bunch.
Okay.
Triangle?
No.
I thought he was...
That was a bad...
Nice.
...read on me.
I think some circle.
Like, just some heavies at those ranges would be pretty good.
Okay.
There you go.
Yee-haw.
Shit.
He has his crit.
I'm a bit scared there.
Oh, no.
Oh, good idea.
Nice.
That was so good.
Yay!
See?
The panic button being the square.
That was it.
Like, if you're getting pressured and you're nervous, the square.
That was so good.
Okay.
We got to get a punish on that.
He is giving you...
He's handing you his life when he does that.
What do I do?
I guess triangle, but you're kind of far away.
But at least X.
Like, the chop.
At least X.
Nice.
Oh, shit.
Oh, my god.
That's fine.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
You can have it.
Let's block it out.
No.
I wanted to do something pointy.
Triangle.
Snap.
At least...
Yeah.
Perfect.
At least there's something.
Okay.
No.
Stop.
That was good.
Fuck you.
Okay.
Block it out.
And then...
Yeah.
Block it out.
Walk back.
And then reset when he starts spamming that.
Okay.
I was trying to grab him, but he grabbed me back.
Loser.
Nice.
Such a loser.
Fair...
He got lucky.
That was bullshit.
Okay.
Yeah.
That forward heavy kick, what's a ban in that?
He's dealing with that really well.
Oh, my god.
Nice.
Yeah.
So instead of the forward heavy kick, we can just do...
Sorry.
Instead of forward circle, we can do stand circle or down forward circle.
Oh, my god.
The big punch or the big sweep.
Let's not do the bicycle kick.
He knows.
Nice.
Let's get some squares when he gets closer.
Okay.
It's okay.
I don't know why that worked, but it worked.
I don't know either.
That shouldn't have worked.
Okay.
But he was not going to jump now.
Oh, fuck.
That will work up closer.
Like, if you get close to him, he's going to jump.
If you get close to him and do a couple of squares and then do it, it will work better.
But from far away, he's ready.
There you go.
You can get close to him and do it.
Okay.
Yeah.
Let's block it out.
Nice.
Exactly.
Nice defense.
Oh.
I love the idea.
I love the idea, though.
Perfect.
Okay.
Oh.
We got to have a combo there.
We got to work on that.
Yeah.
Okay.
Block it out.
Oh.
Oh, no.
He sure won't get to see me.
What the hell?
I hate you.
No, no.
You're playing good.
Oh, my God.
That was footsies.
You found the perfect spacing and you whip punish him.
That was actually amazing.
Yay.
Yeah.
You saw the perfect range to use that.
Okay.
Let's practice something.
Let's go to the corner.
All right.
Okay.
Yeah.
So, you can hold...
You know the reset button, right?
To reset the training mode?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So, hold to the right and press that.
Oh, what?
Just hold right and then press that reset button.
Oh, shit.
What the fuck?
Hold right instead.
Oh, right.
Sorry.
I don't know my directions.
There you go.
I was giving you a second chance there, but yeah.
Okay.
Now, let's pause the training mode.
I felt the 50-50.
That's true.
Now, let's go to dummy settings.
Okay.
And see how it says always punish counter?
Oh, yeah.
Let's change that to normal.
Normal.
Or standard.
Standard?
Yeah, yeah.
Okay.
And now, let's do DI.
So, you see here when it hits the wall like that?
Yeah.
When you're doing the corner.
So, if you don't get the big slowdown and it hits the wall like that, you can't do your command grab.
Yeah.
The triangle.
And I saw you hesitating when that happened against the Kumisu.
You recognize that you can't do command grab.
You can't do command grab there.
Yeah.
What you can do instead to keep it as easy as possible is just down triangle, the Lariat.
Like, that's the...
Oops.
Sorry.
That's weird.
Yeah.
That's the...
Look down.
Okay.
That's the easiest thing you can do.
The slightly better version, if you're comfortable doing it, would be down forward and X.
Forward, X.
Okay.
Like, hold down forward.
And then do tap X.
And then while also holding down forward.
Forward, then tap triangle.
So you're going to get that medium and it's going to cancel into the Lariat.
Oh, okay.
Oh, shit.
So you got to do one X and then one triangle.
And then it's going to be the rhythm.
It's going to be like bum bum.
Like X triangle.
All while holding down forward.
Perfect.
Okay.
You just did a special cancel.
You canceled your normal.
That medium punch.
Into Lariat.
And there you go.
Okay.
You got a combo.
So if you're walking, like say you're walking left and right and then do a random DI.
Yeah.
Try to move around a little bit just to get a feel for it and then get into that position and then try to do that combo.
There you go.
That's what you do.
Yay!
That's what you do at the wall.
Oh my God.
If you get the slow down, you do command grab.
I'm learning.
If it doesn't do the slow down, they bounce into the wall.
That's what you do.
Yeah.
Just do that.
Beautiful.
You got it.
Yay!
All right.
Yeah.
That's a combo.
I'm ready.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
Because you could have killed that Akuma off.
My first combo.
A few times with that.
Perfect.
All right.
Let's go.
I'll do one more rank game and then we'll call it.
Sounds good.
Take a break.
No.
This has been awesome.
You've made a lot of progress.
Oh my God.
I'm doing it.
I'm learning.
It's okay.
If I fuck up round robin one, I still have round robin two.
Yeah.
I think the thing is the first one is just not as important.
We all get a chance to feel it out.
So I can sandbag technically.
So if I sandbag, they'll not train for me.
We can just claim it's sandbagging.
See, let's keep that secret, keep that inside and then just say, yeah, I was totally sandbagging.
That's why they beat me so badly.
Yeah.
Exactly.
Like I did.
Yeah.
For sure.
My coach told me to.
We don't have to say that far.
We can just say you had a surprise strategy that you told nobody about and lied to your coach about.
Yeah.
Exactly.
Oh, shit.
Whoops.
I'm not paying attention.
Nice.
That's not what I wanted.
Oh, perfect.
This is what I wanted to do.
Yeah.
There you go.
Easy.
It's because I'm a pro.
Coming second nature.
Oh, my God.
Free.
Let's get predicted, bitch.
Oh, my God.
No, bitch.
You fuck it.
You don't deserve that.
They kind of do.
They kind of reacted really well.
They did not deserve it.
I'm going to slap you.
Get over here.
I'm going to fucking slap you.
The slap is great.
Yeah.
The slap is a really good slap.
Really good move at that range.
Get out of here.
That's fucking right.
Oh, shit.
What?
Two plus.
But block.
Triangle.
Oh.
Yeah.
That's the idea.
When you block a super, just get the triangle.
Oh.
No.
Almost.
It's okay.
You tried it, though.
That was good.
Okay.
Just got to work your way in.
No.
He saw weakness.
Let's just do some slaps.
Let's do some smaller buttons in this scenario.
No.
That's okay.
He got me.
He understood the homework.
Nice.
That was tricky.
That was a good time to use that.
Up close like that.
Oh, shit.
It's all right.
You deserve it more clearly.
That's cool.
Triangle.
No.
Okay.
Let's block it out.
Let's block it out a little.
That's okay.
Lariat.
He knows now.
Okay.
Block.
Triangle.
Oh, you're too far.
Yeah.
I think I'm too far.
Oh, okay.
He grabbed you.
You deserve it.
No.
Hold on.
You still have level three.
What?
Okay.
I guess he deserves that.
There was just a moment when he was going super ham and you were getting counter hit.
Yeah.
You threw away too much health there.
But you're playing good otherwise.
Oh, no.
Yeah.
When you hit them out of the air, just let them land.
Every time you try to do something there, it doesn't work.
Yeah.
Perfect.
Oh.
He grabbed me.
That's fucking right.
I saw that.
There we go.
Oh, no.
Nice.
Use your...
Oh.
Oops.
It's cool.
Just block it out.
Oh, no.
Nice.
Sweet.
There you go.
Oh.
I was trying to press R1.
Bro, please leave me alone.
What?
That's his command grab.
Yeah.
You have to jump that.
It's tricky.
Oh, my god.
He teleports at you.
Nice.
Very good.
Oh, no.
Wait.
Did I get that?
Yeah.
No.
Oh, no.
Just hold down back here.
Just block.
He might mess up.
Or not.
Okay.
He messed up.
Nice.
Nice defense.
No.
It's cool.
See...
No.
He did the heavy kick and you were mashing again.
So, you got hit after.
But if you had blocked...
Really?
Oh, I didn't realize I was mashing.
Yeah.
Nice.
We just gotta fight that impulse a little bit here and there.
I can't help it.
Yes.
It's not easy.
I understand.
See?
Same thing again.
Yeah.
Nice.
Really good.
And now you have the life lead, right?
Bro, why are you so...
Why are you so defensive?
Yeah.
When he does that, you want to jump.
Okay.
Oh.
No.
Okay.
Nice.
Yeehaw.
Next time, if you get a DI, we're gonna level three.
Just... but you don't have to worry about it.
Just play the game normal.
Did you see?
Oh my god!
Did you hear that?
No.
It's okay.
Yes, you did.
I was like...
I was like, he's crouched.
Listen.
Yeah.
If you can...
If you are ready, you can react to anything in the game with that level three.
Like, that is...
Really scary.
All right.
Oh my god.
I broke his win streak.
I'm happy.
What the hell?
I'm happy to break somebody's win streak and end it with that.
Thank you.
We gotta...
We gotta work on this.
I don't even want it done!
I gave him too many!
That's exactly...
That is the textbook one and done.
You lose the first one, you hit him with the raw level three to steal the second one, and then you run away.
That is worse than losing after the first win.
That guy's gonna...
He's gonna train up.
He's gonna find you.
He's gonna remember me.
That's all I wanted.
He's gonna find you and demand the set.
He's gonna remember me.
Yes.
Absolutely.
Oh, yes.
All right.
GG's.
Thank you for the coaching session.
No, that was awesome.
Yeah.
That was...
I finally learned how to block.
I fucking did it.
Right.
And you see the value of it, right?
It wasn't just me telling you to block and you getting mauled.
You saw how you blocked and it gave you wins, right?
There's a direct...
Yay!
...correlation there.
So that's awesome to see.
So...
Sounds good.
Yeah.
Take a good break.
You earned it.
Let me know if you got any more questions.
And...
Good practice.
Good session.
Yay!
All right.
GG's.
Later, Dokie.
Bye.
Bye-bye.
Later.
Okay.
Good session.
Alert's back on.
What's up, everybody?
What's up?
She learned a lot that session, I feel like.
And she really surprised me with her reactions.
Just the fact that she started blocking a few times and then punishing.
And then I liked her neutral.
Her neutral was good.
Got to see how much is retained.
The thing is, I'm confident it's okay because not...
There wasn't much tech.
I didn't...
Like, we went through some tech in training mode, which that's going to come and go.
It was just the natural rhythm of her play, which was way better.
She blocked.
And then it went back to neutral.
And when she goes back to neutral, she plays better.
So that was, on a fundamental level, just a better rhythm of approaching.
That was awesome.